let's get some official response now
from the Mexican government to the news
of this Caravan Caravan and the
criticism from President Trump and his
administration Iran mo Gutierrez is the
Mexican ambassador to the u.s. mr.
ambassador thanks for being here thank
you very much bread your thoughts on
today what the president has tweeted and
what the administration is saying well
thank you first for the chance to
address this issue this evening I think
it's important it has certainly raised
attention here two quick things
the first one is Mexico's migration
policy is to seek that any migration is
legal safe orderly and respectful of
basic human rights and that's the way we
act upon immigration we certainly do not
advocate for irregular immigration from
our Nationals of or any other country
the second thing is that in fact our
authorities the US and Mexico
cooperation is very good on the matter
and I'll give you an example just last
year we convene a joint summit in Miami
authorities from the US and Mexico
precisely to address this issue we're
working together a to foster development
in Central American countries in order
really to address the could the the the
root causes of immigration and also to
do a better job in managing immigration
in a way again that it's legal safe and
orderly so specifically on this Caravan
understanding that it does happen
annually and it's used by some groups as
a fundraising activity really are you
going to do something different this
year we are doing first of all number
one the first thing is that you're
rightly mentioned this is not in you in
a sense it's largely intended to call
attention on the rights of migrants in
Mexico number two is we are our
migration authorities are looking at as
appropriate either to repatriate these
people or to offer humanitarian relief
to them in Mexico and by the way we have
been in contact with the US Embassy in
Mexico since March 25 precisely to
address it and that's why I appreciate
the opportunity to clarify this issue
here this evening
Master you your country has pretty
strict immigration laws you as William
mentioned deport tens of thousands of
Hondurans and Salvadorans and
Guatemalans every year we do it is in
the best interest of all nations the
Central Americans ourselves and the u.s.
to assure that people don't migrate
irregularly
it's actually very dangerous and that is
why just for example in 2016 Mexico
repatriated respecting the rights of
people repatriated around a hundred and
fifty three thousand Central American
that's a lot of people in 2017 that
number was around a hundred thousand and
the figures so far for these years are
on forty thousand so we do we do work to
assure that migration is legal safe and
ordered so in that sense you understand
where President Trump is coming from in
this policy I think it's very important
we certainly understand the concern or
only that President Trump has but people
in the United States here have about
immigration and I have to say that
Mexico is now largely a country that
receives immigrants it's it's a source
and a destiny of immigration so we we
understand this very clearly and what
we're trying to do precisely is to work
with the United States and Central
Americans first again to address the the
cost of immigration because if we don't
though that is very difficult and second
to achieve migration policies that are
allow us to better manage the phenomenon
so what do you do along your southern
border and is the u.s. helping you we
work it is in our own interest to have a
secure border in our southern border and
we're also in favor of having a secure
border with the United States but
actually bread if we if we do have legal
avenues for people to migrate we do a
better job and we can devote more
resources to actually to the actual
security threats we have we worked
closely with us on different mechanisms
regarding immigration in
we share border and also in our southern
border has the drug problem increased or
decreased in recent weeks just last year
Brett we had two very important
high-level strategic dialogues with the
United States in order to address drug
trafficking and the way we're dealing
with this is that we really need to see
it as a market issue there is certainly
a supplied element to this there's a
demand element to this and what we
agreed with the United States
authorities is that we must really
disrupt the business operations of
transnational organized crime if we only
go against the head of cartels that we
do and quite successfully the problem is
that the market remains and we're not
really able to solve clearly the you
know the issue so we need to disrupt
their business models we're working very
closely with security agencies here in
the United States precisely for that
purpose so you know that the president
this administration has linked helping
with the border and the immigration
issue directly with negotiations on
NAFTA the last tweet the president had
today
Mexico was making a fortune on NAFTA
they have very strong border laws ours
are pathetic with all the money they
make from the US hopefully they will
stop people from coming through their
country into ours at least until
Congress changes our immigration laws
what do you think about that linkage we
first of all it is our in our own best
interest and that's a way we see it to
assure that migration is safe legally
and ordered the same happens we work on
cooperation on security matters with the
United States because it's also on our
best interests and we will continue to
do so now on trade what it's very
important it's not in our view has been
largely a successful agreement for the
three countries it is 25 years old it
needs updating and modernizing and
that's why we're focusing with the US
and our Canadian friends in finding a
solution that it's win-win-win for the
three countries are you optimistic that
that's going to come to a conclusion
quite clear that there are some
difficult issues to tackle
we're not there yet I think we're in a
better shape today than we were a year
ago I think that the negotiating teams
are gaining ground there are important
issues that we haven't solved but I
think there's a strong commitment on the
part of the three partners to try to
solve this there's too much at stake for
Mexico certainly but also for Canada for
the United States and quite clearly a
lot of employment on the three countries
depends on a successful and after a
negotiation it's not so much right about
how much we trade among ourselves
although that's important but how are we
in fact producing together to export to
other regions of the world
mr. ambassador we appreciate your time
you're welcome back any time thank you
very much it's a pleasure to be here
this evening thank you